january
um
the first item on the agenda
is apologies for absence
so we've got apologies from councillor
pennington and councillor watson's
substituting and we've also had
apologies from council a
thank you very much indeed thank you
the second item on the agenda minutes of
the meeting
held on the 5th of october
i'll just do a quick page turner
pages 3
9 ten
and eleven
i'm happy to propose from the chair
there's a true record
casa wish me thank you secondly
uh can we have a vote please okay
[Music]
uh chair sorry um this is um uh julie
mashi here apologies to to interrupt i
haven't got a raised hand option
unfortunately on my uh
on my options on zoom it was just a
really small minor point if i may just
to correct the spelling of my surname if
that's possible um just at the bottom of
page seven the uh the c and the s are
the wrong way around
um if that could just be corrected in
the final minutes that would be much
appreciated
sorry to interact
that would be done thank you very much
thank you
right thank you so
those in four
we just show them again just
and those against
and the abstentions
okay
thank you very much
all right we've got no matters of rising
so declaration of interests members with
interest should refer to the agenda item
describe the nature of their interest
when the item is considered
item four
agreements of the gender items chart
there isn't sorry there is no part two
items so that's a mistake on the agenda
right we're not going to have the risk
registrant 15. okay
right so we don't have to take a vote
okay
um urgent matters
brought forward the mission of the chair
i do not have any matters
no no
okay
so we're going to item six grand
thornton update report pages 12 to 35.
um i presume julie you're going to
do this
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much indeed can everybody hear me okay
thank you perfect um so councillors um
good afternoon uh happy new year to
everybody um the report that you have in
front of you today is um our usual
progress update report in terms of where
we are um in the
2020 2020-21 audit cycle
so there's two pieces of work that have
been ongoing since the date of the last
audit committee in october
one is in relation to finalizing our
work on the financial statements audit
you'll see on page 15 of your papers in
the first column of our commentary um
the update we gave at the last committee
on the 5th of october of those areas
that were still to be finalized to
finalize the audit
i'm pleased to say that
those
uh outstanding items have been finalized
with the exception of the items that are
set out further down in the paragraph
and since in writing since writing an
issue in this report to the papers we
have made a good progress on the
outstanding areas as well um the main
area related to some further work we had
to do around
getting some support through technical
consultations around
issues that were apparent in the um the
council's values report around a
material valuation uncertainty we've had
this appear in quite a number of our
local authorities on different groups of
assets i hated to add so in in torres
particular case it came up on leisure
assets we've had some come up on car
parks some with across the boards so
there's been different circumstances
coming up in in different audits
depending on the professional judgments
that have been made by those valuers so
we've had to get some support and some
clarification around that and um earlier
this week i've been consulting with
david just to to finalize um that in
understanding what the position is on
the assets as a whole so that we can
finalize the word and of the opinion
um
once we've got that opinion finalized um
this week then we'll be in a position to
issue our final opinion so
the the sign of that is very imminent
and we look to finalize that very
shortly
the second area work relates to over the
page which is in relation to our housing
benefit work we obviously as you will be
aware complete the audit of the housing
benefit return to the dwp
that work is progressing well and we're
due to finalize and sign off that return
this week
and there's been no significant issues
that have come out of the testing that
we've carried out from that work um
this year which is which is great to
hear
so in terms of the the the 2021 position
um we set out then um on page
17 of your papers the position where we
are with the order deliverables for the
2021 year um and also for completeness
we've started to add on the deliverables
in readiness for starting the planning
process
for the 21 22 audit cycle as well
there are some additional bits of
information there's as in our usual
fashion we've included some some wider
sort of sector updates for
um for councillors to make you aware of
other things that happen within the
sector and any sort of relevant um
public reports that will be of uh of use
to um to committee members those are
there for information i don't propose to
go those in any great detail but again
if there's any specific questions i'll
i'll do my most to try and support
members with any questions they they
have on those
so that's our um
uh our update report chair but happy to
take any specific questions thank you
thank you julie for your report um
i've got a concern why
grantham and thornton have taken eight
months to raise the issue
that you mentioned first of all about
leisure centers
um torres laser center are not valued
upon the income levels they generate but
on um depreciation replacement costs
essentially the rebuild cost so the
material uncertainty would not apply to
toilet valuation of leisure assets
and
it's particularly concerning that this
has been raised you say earlier this
week today is tuesday it was relate it
was made to us yesterday the 17th monday
why has this been raised
almost as the door of the governance
committee has been opened today
surely it should not take eight months
for this to come forward
if i could come on back back on that
that this issue hasn't been raised for
the first time today this was
this was present in the audit finance
report we did present to this committee
um in october we did highlight that
there was a difference of opinion
between management and the valuer at
that point in time what we've been doing
since that audit committee is trying to
establish whether or not actually to
some extent whether it matters or not
because what we've been trying to
understand is the composition of assets
first of all that has been subject to
this uncertainty but also we have been
gathering some information about the
extent of these uncertainties across the
local government population as well so
this
whilst i've asked some further follow-up
questions to the council's valuer this
week there has been a num of elements of
work that have been going on both behind
the scenes and i have been keeping in
correspondence with david
about the work that we've been
undertaking on this yes it was only this
week i absolutely agree that we've asked
for specific follow-up information
around the values that were involved
but this is not the first time we've put
this before the audit committee we did
highlight the fact that we would need to
consider this particular concern uh as
part of our opinion when we fed back the
audit finance report um in in october
but i absolutely recognize um the
concern that you raise um i had a
discussion earlier today with with the
council section 151 officer we
absolutely
recognized the time period that's been
involved here um it's not a
straightforward
item and we do need to make sure we go
through the appropriate processes but we
absolutely do take on board that there's
scope to improve the timeless around
this and we will seek to work with the
authority to improve such a situation uh
going forward
would you like to comment on this
yeah
[Music]
moderation of the audits across this
sector because
the information regarding the value that
we've got in the books for the
legislators well that was available back
when you came to do the audit in june
and the
um issue that we don't value the
leisure centers based on income you know
that like you said has been discussed
previously in october is some of this
delayed due to the fact that you've
having to moderate consistency across
your local authority audits and we've
just been caught up in the weight of our
grandfather's policy approach more than
anything
um
i probably used the words moderation
early when we had the conversation it's
not so much a moderation as such
as we go through a number of our audits
things will emerge you know when we
started our audit process for the 2021
audit year for all of our local
authorities there was an expectation
that some authorities in line with the
rick's guidance risks is the
professional standards that valuers have
to follow when they conduct their um
formal valuations we were aware from the
current extent guidance that ricks had
published at the time that all the
audits started that there was an
expectation that some authorities would
issue these uncertainty
paragraphs what we want to absolutely
make sure that we do is not just modify
opinions in all cases where these
uncertainties exist what we have to make
sure is that we understand the scale of
it we have to understand
that the nature of the assets that are
involved but i guess the specific
circumstances for torrid is that um
in your case there was a difference of
opinion effectively because you had your
professional valuer quite clearly saying
to you
um based on the market position and
based on the rick's guidance that he
completes his valuations by he believed
that uncertainty existed whereas in
management's case you um did not support
the view of that value and therefore
didn't make any disclosure generally in
most of the other authorities that we've
had
they will follow the advice of the
follower and include the disclosures
accordingly so we've had to look at this
one in a slightly different way to try
and um i suppose get
get understanding from both sides and
take into account both points of view
here to come to review
one is something of a scale that we need
to be concerned about but actually
um do we take the view of the value or
do we take the view of management and
therefore where does that leave things
with the account so
moderation i would say it's not so much
we have to look at all of the audit and
say you've got this you've got this
you've got this you've got this but it's
also about it is about gaining some
intelligence about what's happening in
the market because if you've got one
group of valuers saying we've got
concerns around x and we've got another
group of values saying something
different we just need to try and make
sure that we understand you know
what the kind of the sort of the picture
is across the board to make sure that we
are taking appropriate judgments as
auditors around what's happening in the
market and indeed we do also consult our
own valuers so we engage our own value
expert expertise where necessary to give
us some
um uh informed opinion before we decide
how we want to take things forward so
it's not something we just sort of
uh take and take as read you know we do
make sure that we are consulting
appropriately with with relevant
professional um uh expertise to to come
out with our judgments as well but i
absolutely i said i'm not going to hear
and and sort of defend the position
around the timeliness i absolutely take
on board you know what what the
committee has said and indeed um and
recognized david's frustrations and we
absolutely will make sure
to um to to improve that situation for
for the future
okay thank you julia but notwithstanding
everything you just said we're still
looking just at the replacement building
costs
rather than
anything
yes so it's alleged services are on are
on a drc basis and what what i suppose
it's important to say a material
valuation uncertainty
isn't saying that the value is wrong
uh which is why we're not talking about
a potential qualification to the audit
opinion here
it's it's a sort of an additional kind
of um
advisory clause i suppose for want of a
better description that value has given
to say
um he he you can place less certainty on
that figure than you ordinarily would in
normal market conditions so
when we um decide that we have to refer
to that in our audit opinion what we
call an emphasis of matter we're not
qualifying the opinions because we're
not saying we think your asset
valuations are wrong what we're trying
to say is we recognize the uncertainty
that that valuer has given in his
reports
um
we need to emphasize that in our opinion
words in the problem that we have at the
moment is
we can't emphasize something that's not
already disclosed in the accounts
because an emphasis of matter is meant
to say
as set out in notes x of your accounts
we draw the reader's attention to this
particular issue that we want to
emphasize because of this uncertainty
the difference we've got with torrid at
the moment is because you've got that
difference of view between the valuer
that's saying is an uncertainty and the
management's saying there isn't so
there's no disclosure at the moment we
have no disclosure to emphasize if that
makes sense so we need to take a view as
to one where the disclosure needs to be
in there and two we can then actually
put the word in together to say
we emphasize this particular paragraph
to your attention i hope that makes
sense trying to keep it as simple as
simple as i possibly can
but
what i would say
we can't draw attention and emphasize a
matter that's not not disclosed i
suppose what i'm trying to say
okay um
what i hear from
an answer you gave previously is that
this should not impede
this matter going forward and you're
looking for a very quick resolution to
the situation yes we are we absolutely
are we absolutely are and as i said it
wasn't helped by the fact obviously
various team members have been off the
last couple of weeks with christmas and
new year break as well so i was really
hopeful and i give an indication to
david that we would finalize this ahead
of the audit committee so i could come
to the committee's day and say we're all
done or signed and and we are very close
to that it's just um just some
logistical things that we've just not
been able to quite get over the line by
the time of today's meeting but um will
be very very very shortly
okay thank you very much indeed julie
thank you
thank you i'm going to
ask you for any further questions
no further questions so um
we note this report
so if
we're all in agreement we will note the
report
thank you very much and move on to the
next item
which is item number seven
the fraud assessment pages 36-45
and we will now hear from devon audit
partnership
yeah good afternoon to you hopefully you
can hear me okay
yes we're hearing you that's that's
great obviously paul middlemast from
from dap
um so yes so um this is uh our annual
assessment on
how torridge is is minimizing the risk
of fraud and corruption it it uses first
cipher code of practice
as the basis
for the assessment
um
paragraph two of the document so that
outlines the scale of a problem
um in for the public sector and local
government sector um
with the with the table on page 37 sort
of highlighting
some of the typical
fraud um impacts relating to the
local authorities and so on
um i suppose i would i would also say
obviously as well as the loss of
of money there's the actual income sorry
the impact
on councils where there's lots of
whereas um
fraud and corruption in terms of poor
decision-making it's it's like to have a
poor control culture
um and poor administration and so on so
there's lots of related issues as well
as loss of of public money as well
um appendix a of the document um which
is uh from paris paragraph seven
um provides the the actual assessment
i won't i won't provide
i won't go through the document in
significant details but but i'll just i
suppose highlight some of the
important elements
from from the document so
effective action really starts with
um good awareness and um identification
of what the sort of possible fraud risks
might occur
um and that's about having um a fraud
risk register and and the overall
council risk register which we've
obviously
found to be in place and the council's
you know in our views have identified
what the significant fraud risk
will be
um obviously the the role of the audit
committee in this respect is is
important um
including discussing this assessment um
reviewing the counter fraud policy and
strategy
um and consideration of the uh annual
government statement
um
we also note there's obviously there's
codes of contact for staff and members
and other important arrangements such as
a listing of members interests
and gifts and hospitality arrangements
um the these will also support the um
openness and transparency which are also
important for important from a
government standpoint
and then there's a range of different
activities in in the council to try to
identify
um and prevent fraud or see there's um
the the regular participation in the
national fraud initiative
um
i might say our our own intent audits um
um normally have a sort of fraud element
too in terms of where where fraud might
occur
um and we we we test for them
um and also in terms of dap we have our
own sort of highly specialist fraud team
which is available for
count fraud work but also
to provide fraud awareness and
communication and so on
um so
overall as a summary um we consider
arrangements to be
largely effective and appropriate
recognizing that
it's very difficult to reduce the risk
of fraud and corruption to nothing
but can i um open this assessment to
committee members for discussion and any
questions
all right
doug uh you've got a question yeah thank
you um
age 37 you've got the um
the estimated local government fraud
loss
why is it dated 2013. that's nine years
old today
yes and that's a good point and we can
obviously only use the current um
estimates provided by cypher
so um as you can probably appreciate um
it's very difficult for any um
i suppose central organization to
estimate the the risk of
the amount of money that's actually
being lost
so that's that's necessary that's that's
the latest figures that that citroen
provided
right so it's nine years out of date
categories that you've got i mean i i do
take the point that it's estimated uh
loss
but you know just one that jumps out of
me blue badge scheme misused 46 million
it's this
loss of car parking and things like this
you're referring to them is that because
people have got a revenge
yes this would be misuse of blue barrage
schemes um trying to avoid i suppose
parking fees and and so on i mean these
are just indicative
and i know what tvs are
these are old figures although they're
the latest ones we that's it for a
release for the public
from local authority sector
well
the fact that they're nine years every
day and they're all estimated
i don't find there's an overall
credibility but when something's
presented to me in that format but
that's the latest available information
that's the latest you've got
does anybody else wish to raise any
issue on the report
no not really i think
[Music]
um in
paragraph nine you say the authority
does not have a dedicated counter fraud
team
and in paragraph 10 you say that
successful cases of probing forward
corruption will be reported in the local
paper
now i'm not asking you to go into
specific details here with individuals
but my challenge question if you like is
are we effective in rooting out fraud in
torridge do we find any
do we find a lot
are you satisfied that
we are robust in challenging fraud here
or do we not find any but are you happy
that by not finding any
we are taking the appropriate steps
what comments would you make along those
lines
so so
i had to suggest that with um various
offices about the amount of so so for
instance articles in in the paper and
told well we've not really identified
any instances of of fraud to go in the
paper
um
fraud is um very often quite hard to
find um
and
i i've said already that we we look for
it and the officers have various
activities to look for for fraud and
where it might occur and so on
um i
personally i don't think it's a
i think it's a low fraud risk area
but there's always a point and i think i
think
a dedicated specialist fraud officers
would say that fraud exists everywhere
but um
um
i think the assessment says we we don't
think that's it is a high risk a fraud
area
okay
thank you very much thank you for your
report which
again
i'm happy to know to the committee
yeah yes they're satisfied so the report
is truly noted thank you oh sorry i
think i just asked one question do we
guess that is do we pay for the service
partnership do we pay for this was it
free we paid for dead nordic partnership
yes
potentially council must be there for
pulling our role of internal order
thank you
right i will move on to item nine
progress
sorry united eight
reports issued to date pages 46 to 52
and
this
in the main have been reports that have
been previously circulated
so
if you would like to add continued pool
yeah
that's fine and before we
but before we get to the uh reports um i
i suppose i just like to feedback the
results of our own external assessment
um as members will know we had a um
a public uh
external assessment recently against the
public sector internal that standards
um
the the the external assessors provided
us provided us with a a generally
conforms marking
and very very free markings and and
generally conforms is
is the highest one
um
of the markings available um and um
identified i suppose some minor
observations and recommendations for
improvement but the report is now being
sent to the debt management board which
um i think members um here are our
members of of that committee which will
provide more detail on the um on the
assessments and um
how we can make our
service even even better than it
currently is
um so i just thought i'd provide that um
an issue update um so um going on to the
reports um so um as the chair said we've
we've issued these sort of five reports
um to members for their um visibility
um but we also provide the summary on
each audit um in in this report
um and i'll just uh just just go through
them briefly and make some
comments um on them so
starting with with payroll and we
provide a substantial on that um which
is uh really good to see the council
has has has moved to their new payroll
system my trends um
and um we um
to confirm or we can confirm those core
controls are in place over the payroll
system
um i might also say that the um the new
i trent payroll system is it was also
having a
a beneficial impact on on council
operations in terms of um
making things a lot more
what i might call swishy in terms of
workflows and so on
and so reducing um paperwork and so on
um
in terms of um corporate health and
safety um again we confirm that uh
arrangements in place
um to
for councils to meet um science fair
teams in this area
we did identify some work that needs to
be done
um
on some of its inspections um which
which to some extent is the sort of
postcode with 19 sort of
impact of not working in offices and so
on
um
but um the the council's um
recruiting was agreed to recruit an
additional officer
um to help meet that need as well as to
support
emergency planning
in terms of hardware services um yes so
we provided
a limited insurance in this
area
staff um related issues uh we think have
have had a lot to do with with the
i suppose reduction in um arrangements
uh in in this area but but we're we're
confident and can see that management
has got a good plan to address the
areas of of weakness that we've
identified and they've identified and is
taking them forward quickly
so we think that so those those
weaknesses are being addressed
um and
are being resolved so um
at a um a more strategic level i suppose
we highlight that there perhaps could be
more construction on
the costs and benefits of of the harbour
obviously has its um
those with annual losses um occurring
um and then um last couple so we've got
um
recruitment selection retention again
we had a look at the uh recruitment and
retention selection processes of council
again we're quite content
that arrangements are in place to
recruit people based upon merit and fair
and open competition
um and um that recruitment hr team
provides uh good good service to to
management areas
um and you know this is one area where
for instance high trend is making a
beneficial impact on
on speeding up recruitment um and make
it more efficient
and then last last summer areas on
emergency planning
and again um
we were satisfied with arrangements
obviously they've had a lot to do with
um in the last couple years on the
mentioned planning but there's been
other instances and incidents and so on
um
we make a couple of minor things about
reviewing the
emergency plan itself and the business
continuity plan
and um we also
agreed that the um that the emergency
plan could be reviewed by the lead
member
um as as these this is a statutory
requirement to have a have a
plan um so and that's that's my uh
summary does um anyone have any
questions about any of his any of his
work
i i note with the harvest services that
it will come back to us at a later date
when the recommendations are looked at i
personally don't have any further
questions
um do any members of the committee want
to make any comments on these issues
no
so
with that
we duly note your report
and thank you very much
thank you very much
right we will
now move on to item nine progress
against all the actions pages 53-54
to receive a report from the 151
officer
okay thank you chair
well we get audited throughout the year
by the devin audience partnership in
their role as internal artists for the
council and to produce various reports
and those reports will have actions that
they believe management should undertake
and sometimes management disagrees with
those actions but at the end of the day
there's a read list of actions the
management degree yes thank you for your
findings we'll go away and change some
processes
and the report you've got only two pages
it was of all the audit reports
published in 2021 there's 92 agreed
actions
um 50 of them have been completed which
is 54
30 of them are open i either still
within the time frame that management
has moved with the external auditors and
12 are late which represent 13
of the agreed actions
and then simply the next page of the
report
details the agreed actions
uh which are late
and management's response as to what's
happening with regards to them and
they're ordered in terms of the priority
the audit assigned to the agreed action
so high obviously in the highest
priority
low an opportunity to be in the lowest
independent medium in the middle
so they're listed in order of the
severity of the audit findings and
they're listed in management's responses
detailed there so i've chased managers
up prior to this meeting so where are we
through these actions
um i didn't intend to go through them
one by one they were there there for
information just to give you a flavor
of
what management does in response to
these
orders
um
some are understandable in terms of i
think one a little bit lower down in it
one where actually
the central deadline has moved from
government in terms of some backs
um
compliance issues so that's actually
moved anyway so you don't always happen
to
one towards the top and multi-factor
authentication
and it started the process and then the
government announced that people needed
to go back and work from home which is
delayed because you need to actually
deal with the person present so
we mentioned the harbour board report
there was gave limited assurance and one
of the things was we need to get people
appointed and suitably trained in on the
course and the next available course
is marked so we can't do it before the
deadline that was november that's in
process but it's not met the original
deadline
um
i say i'm open to questions but
obviously i won't know the detail of
each one of these uh marketing fans i
might have to take them away if you were
to ask me any detailed questions um any
comments
right thank you very much david no uh we
haven't got any comments from the floor
so we truly note your report thank you
very much
and we'll move on to the next item
which is
item 10 because the governance pages
55-70 to receive a report from the
service improvement officer so welcome
chris and thank you
um
and your government statement
this is very updated on governance
arrangements
um
sit first honestly produced um
a set of principles of good governance
for councillors to holla
and the court of congress is basically
our statement saying
yeah we're going to do all that
um
i want to hang out three hurdles for is
on page 56
and to table those and it's interesting
um
this is kind of a summary of our
government's arrangements what i do is i
hold the database
and it's all the things that the council
should do i have invented like seven
spreadsheets together
um and each all time i spend probably
a month going through it and do a full
audit i measures that they're actually
using temples for the current year and
it's the summary where i've got to
um on f4 it says 95 seconds actually
that's not 100 percent so basically
um after a lot of different areas and
there's kind of hundreds of different
sub principles
there's two areas where we're not 100
compliance and one of those is code
related one of them is just some
information that's out to date on the
staff internet now i've been doing this
for nine years now it's never been this
good basically
um
there's obviously quite a few areas
where we're kind of falling short
um
so in my time my nine years you know
this is kind of
i'm quite pleased with this we're kind
of getting there in terms of being in
between clients which
i didn't think was really possible
and i'm kind of thinking this time next
year we'll get there
so i'm kind of
quite pleased
[Music]
um
that's kind of the seven principles that
suppose it all which is discretely into
the knights so a and b in the middle
affect all the other five principles
so it's kind of very much a dynamic
process that keeps council going on the
straightening arrow
[Music]
i'm sure this looks a bit
a bit messy
but basically i do issues put all the
welcomes
those hospitals on one single
um
page
kind of update each year i try and
simplify it to make it clearer and
updated in terms of any
um responsibility changes so this is the
kind of data shapes are
the people who wanted for governance and
the square box explain the
responsibilities
and this kind of strategic spend on one
clear page hopefully
one of the different those guys would
have been to the council
three members on that says members of
the top house i want to change the full
council now because it's kind of full
council is ever
stronger than its body
but it kind of should sit down exactly
what's happening because the
government's links across the council
both members and officers on one clear
page
i don't know i talked to the report
because that's his managed statements
and what we're going to do i'm trying to
explain it behind that this is database
then we're now doing these things
this email will publish on the website
next to the
governor's statement so i'd like to be
approved to answer your questions as
well
is that anybody got any questions
excellent
very straightforward very clear
very understandable
great graphics
chris
yes of course
we will have that approved so i'm happy
to approve it from the chair
council watson second is
all those in favor
that's unanimous thank you thank you
very much indeed
right moving on to item 11
appointment of extend auditors pages 71
to 78
so
we are to receive a report from the
section 151 issued
[Music]
as you're aware currently
our audit our external audit is provided
by grant thompson
and we got grant
grant funding assigned to us as part of
a
national
procurement of public sector audits
within the local authority sector
primarily and that was done by the
public sector audio appointments body
so
the vast majority of local authorities
signed up for that tender process i i
don't know
something like 325 out of 360 local
authorities
signed up to this
that contract ends with the delivery of
the audit the 2022
so the next year's financial audit order
the financial year 2022-23 will be done
by grandfather and that's the last year
under the current contract
so there's three options available to us
at storage
we could go out and appoint our own
external auditors
we craft jointly with other local
authorities to procure external audit
services or we could opt in to the
public sector or the appointment body
again to do
the tender on behalf of ourselves and
lots of other local authorities
the deadline for opting in is the 11th
of march 2022 and we need full council
approval and they need the minute from
paul council to say that's been done
there was a discussion of section 151
officers across devon to see whether
there's any
scope for doing a dead and wide
procurement and there was no appetite
basically to do that
as much as anything that the
devon county would probably naturally be
the lead they were actually tied in for
beyond the time period
with grant fund i believe it was with
grant parten but they did that i think
they may have gone alone with grand
farms don't quote me this they may have
gone along with their time sales their
contract ends after
uh this contract
so if we went along it's all detailed in
the report sorry would have to establish
an independent audit panel with the
audit appointment panel being made up of
a majority of independent members
i think as members he'll be aware we've
had difficulty recruiting independent
members of an independent vote for this
committee for example so now to get an
audit panel made up of a majority of
independent members would be attacked
um the non-elected members will have the
majority in the appointment of the audit
firm
this would be resource intensive for the
council to do this
we also would have the benefits of any
bulk purchasing power
if we're only going for a relatively
small
tender and annual
audit fee
and we'd have to have ongoing oversight
of the audit contract which at the
moment is done at a higher level
primarily by the public sector audit
appointment budget
and it won't do anything to change the
fact that the audit market at the moment
is actually really difficult um
the external audit companies rather in
recruiting and particularly maintaining
stuff
and the overwhelming majority as is ours
audits are actually not been signed off
yet within the local authority sector
we may go out
to the market and in our lifeclub we
made it with the same firm that we would
have done if we'd gone through the
public sector
audio appointment
approved and just got a higher price
because of our smaller purchasing power
essentially so what i'm looking for from
members here today
is a recommendation to full council that
we opt in to the public sector our
partner body process
and go with grant point it wouldn't
necessarily be with grandfather they
would go out to tender and they would
there's only really about four or five
players in the market grant fountain
price water hours
deloitte says i remember
this i can't remember what the cover is
there's quite a limited number of people
that have
accreditation as much as anything to do
public sector artists so i don't know
who we'd get
it could be grant funds and it could be
spent over or it comes today so
if
to do it ourselves
would it cost more for us to do it
ourselves would be a lot more working
maybe a lot more work i'd almost be
certain it would cost physically the
actual cash would be more because
where does the public sector hold at
grant fountain and delight would bid
because in okay well we'll get the
southwest
that's 50 yards which is
x million pounds a year
are they gonna sharpen the pencil to get
totally district council 50 grand a year
probably not that's not the way they put
their time and effort into them
so there's no
sorry supposed to just just explain
again what you want to pick for we want
a recommendation from this committee to
full council that we opt into
essentially the national tender for
external audit services
i'll propose that we're doing that i
think i suppose better questions i'm
sorry yeah
i'm quite happy to support whatever
recommendation our section one point one
officer was gonna
recommend he's the expert on the council
but i just like to point out you know
the fact that when you read the report
there are a very limited number actually
says nine there's nine companies uk wide
that can actually offer the type of
services that
we're doing here looking for brown ford
and one other i presume it's one of the
big players actually they've got 70 of
the total market
which is a little bit dangerous i think
when you've got two companies that have
got such a large you know section of
local authority work nationwide you know
you always run the risk
they can basically then charge what they
want particularly in this in this day
and age when it's so difficult to
recruit
auditors of the right caliber to
act as you know competition warsaw so
you know i i just make that point yeah
whatever figure they whatever the figure
they asked for
you you've more or less got the bag yeah
you can't say well we want a discount
unless i start negotiation
that was probably before that
we've grabbed not having a little
people working for them
yeah i mean i you know i've been out
here to defend themselves so maybe clash
would say but you know my observation
would be that there's quite a lot of new
auditors every every time we have
another new auditors
retention issues of keeping the auditors
they've got i mean i wouldn't envy a
young person stepping out toward it when
um
you know you
you've thrown in quite quickly into
doing the artist and obviously
particularly the pre-code which is quite
a lot of travel involved in the job yeah
particularly in the southwest so you you
basically may be in manchester birming
and you might
be able to get home most of the time but
when you're in the southwest you get out
operating out bristol and you're going
down to turridge you you stay over in
you know there's lots of factors of
flying my heart beats for
them to the end of the world
but i i still proposed i think it's just
just worth pointing out just as we have
a public meeting the the circumstances
council wants to describe is not uh just
associated with grant thornton the
entire local authority audit market is a
difficult market uh the rules have been
changing since the contracts were put in
place
um
i'm sure you have noted from your
reports on the agenda today about the
redmond review that changes the the type
of ordered work it's it has become a lot
more complex since these contracts were
awarded so there's an expectation
nationally that audit costs will
increase anyway so sure okay well yeah i
mean everything else is increasing now
[Music]
the one concern that i've picked up over
the years is that if we did want to go
out on our own
where we are
we're inhibited by the pool of people
that we can call upon to act as auditors
we're not in university town
the other situation is a great bug there
to me and the committee previously
is that we negotiated the price
and then each year we've had add-ons
which we have challenged
but nonetheless we can't do anything
about it so the price that we're quoted
at the bottom
is subject to increased variation as
time goes by
which is somewhat exasperating for a
council where we like to know how much
money we have in the pot and quantify
what our expenses are going to be yeah
so
um
we've had the proposal
so with that we put the proposal to the
vote
all in favor and that is unanimous
thank you very much everybody
we now move on to
the last item that we will take today
which is the forward plan page 79 on
your agenda
right um
would anybody like to comment on the
forward plan
it's fairly straightforward
and we can take it as ready if you wish
unless we want to vary anything on it
then we will take it as red
we just note that item
so that is julian noted
right
we can now close the meeting thank you
very much for the subs for attending
a short notice
the meeting closed at